[Music]
here he is magnus carlsen it's
apparently cold inside the miami arena
but uh duda he's in a t-shirt he's
looking comfortable and he has made the
first move in his match against magnus
carlsen and simon you were right it's a
queen's pawn opening dude yeah maybe
hoping to catch magnus in
uh in some territory that he wasn't
expecting and what do you think magnus
will go for king's indian nimzo indian
slav
it's really hard to predict with magnus
i mean okay he's actually showing a lot
of respect here right by by playing uh
the nimzo very safe opening and now the
boat the pogo the bogo indian i don't
think we've seen this on the tour really
have we very often really and this is
going to be a marker of whether black is
ambitious or not and you see a trade of
bishops
that normally means that black is trying
to play the game in a very solid safe
way
yeah just trying to avoid memorizing any
long variations here just trying to get
developed simply okay this last move um
not necessarily the only way to play
this opening but black does establish
some influence in the center i'm
expecting black to hurry and get his
king castled
usually duda will do the same and okay
he's kind of
it's a whole bunch of openings and a
whole bunch of opening ideas being mixed
here suddenly we're going towards a
catalan opening
uh white light square bishop will sit on
its longest possible diagonal and
yeah i'm not sure
i mean to be honest this one is uh
almost new to me i've seen this position
before but there's not that much theory
uh that i can help with here
maybe he bit of a surprise
maybe he was uh duder was looking at the
game that magnus had against liam likong
yesterday
because liam got very nice position
didn't he with the white pieces by by
playing this g3 move this idea of
bringing the bishop out next and maybe
he's thinking oh this is this is the way
to try and try and get something against
the magnus and again magnus now
we saw this yesterday when magnus had
black he makes his light squared bishop
a very bad piece but he goes for a very
solid setup yeah and it's quite curious
because uh
dudeo is actually using a weapon that
magnus himself has utilized with the
white pieces and i think he did it
okay he did it in 2010
against luis gallego in the hunty
manchester olympiad
yeah so magnus more used to being on the
white side of these types of positions
right now he's grabbed a pawn and i was
going to say yesterday magnus's secret
to success was creating that kind of
triangle pawn structure with black he
did it in every black game and then he
grabbed a pawn later and he's done it
again today
and
now this pawn push from duda makes it uh
less attractive maybe for magnus to
start pushing pawns on this queen side
and
yeah i mean if white gets that pawn back
the pawn he gambited and he's doing very
well right
and uh what about the absence of dark
square bishops good bad
yet
and it's more about what's on the board
rather than what's off the board i guess
and
i just love white's bishop compared to
the black bishop uh that's that's the
potential it seems to be the key point
doesn't it david you just said they're
the bishops just look at the bishops i
mean black's bishop in these positions
is terrible right
uh and white's bishop has that range
across the board um when the night moves
and this you know if you could win that
pawn back as you say then
i really like white's position again so
yeah like yesterday
yeah exactly so the pressure will be on
magnus i'm i'm guessing here duda is
actually going to bring his knight the
one that hasn't developed out onto the
edge of the board just to go and capture
that black uh pawn on the a3 square
which
uh which piece is due to clicking on it
looks like he's
maybe hovering over his knight
it's funny on the chest 24 play zone all
of the players prefer different
backgrounds on their board oh yeah
that's true dude has maybe the more
traditional kind of
white squares and then kind of dark
brown
like wood yeah the kind of the wooden
type of formation i've seen magnus play
on
this kind of football pitch type of
thing
this kind of filter you can use on the
chess 24 play zone it's literally a
football pitch with a center circle and
a penalty area
but you do see the squares and
i've seen magnus do that on banter blitz
sessions but what do you prefer david
when playing online
i'm boring just stick with the defaults
me too and
well whilst the players are thinking
i just want to mention that we have
another selfie competition where this
time we are asking everyone at home to
tweet a selfie that will impress their
very own ginger gm
simon williams because the winner will
get simon's chest book course on the
hippo defense it's just been released
and uh i have to ask you simon what kind
of selfie would impress you the most
yeah
i'm well as it's the hippo if anyone can
make themselves look like a hippo
i'd be pretty impressed i don't know how
they're supposed to do that but maybe go
and find a river and just jump in
if anyone goes that far they're pretty
much guaranteed to win a very expensive
course so jump in the river pretend
you're a hippo and send us the picture
yeah and if you want to send us the
picture remember landscape mode is the
best then uh tweet your selfie using the
hashtag chesschamps
i'm looking forward to these selfies
me too yeah i wonder if anyone's
actually going to jump in a river now i
i
wonder if anyone's got a pet hippo you
know just lurking in the
garden
hippos are meant to be the most
dangerous creatures aren't they i think
they're
yeah i think they cause more deaths than
anything else yeah that's my knowledge
of the animal well maybe for you know we
have some viewers that for some reason
is going to the zoo today or a safari i
don't know if anyone can get a hippo on
camera that would be a massive
coincidence that stars aligned that's
why it's such a good opening simon the
hippo defense they're the most dangerous
the most killer animal out there yeah
it's it's an interesting opening i mean
i know you you play a bit david as well
especially in bullet chess and uh it's
um
the good thing about the hippo very
quickly is that when you're playing with
white you can control the game a bit
when you're playing with the black
pieces you have to normally adapt to
what your opponent plays so you have to
learn numerous different opening setups
and that takes a lot of time but when
you play the hippo the hippo you can
play against everything it's kind of
what we call a system opening so no
matter really what white does you can go
for the same kind of setup uh so it's
great great for those who don't have as
much time
to learn all the theory and just want to
get into an interesting middle game so
it's got its benefits definitely play as
white
do we see it often on the tour and is it
likely we'll see it today for example
none of these guys play it no no
magnus right playing magnus rajabov
played it
rashboth played it in a must-win
situation didn't he he's quite good at
opening if you really need to win with
the black pieces so yeah you keep all
keep everything on the board so yeah i'm
a better game
uh nepo maybe was it yeah i think that a
long time yeah possibly yeah anyway this
one isn't a hippo this is a kind of mix
between the catalan and the bogo indian
that we mentioned earlier um it's very
much a catalan opening at this point
because of white's light squared bishop
fiend cathode in front of his king and
this last pawn push from duda as white
i was going to say the idea is to stop
black advancing on this side of the
board on this flank and magnus just says
okay you tried to stop me from achieving
my plan i'm going to force it through
anyway and he pushes his b pawn forward
and this allows ompassant
so white here can capture this pawn as
if it just moved one square
so this pawn trying to bypass white's
pawn on the fifth rank this can be
captured
and uh the question is does this help
white does this help black black would
love to take back with his pawn to
connect his pawn structure but
unfortunately there is a pin
on this a-file the black rook in the
corner would fall if you take with the
black pawn right now so i'm expecting
maybe the black knight to jump out and
capture and although black does have
this kind of ugly pawn structure doubled
pawns isolated pawns he is temporarily
still that one pawn up um it's just
about whether white knight can jump in
for example here and there's a pin
still comparing the bishops white's
bishop is far superior to black's bishop
uh yeah just this just looks wrong
somehow or it looks ugly at least what
magnus is doing and this pawn push
i'm slightly surprised to even see duda
think i would just whip this one off in
a heartbeat because if you don't take
this pawn there's a risk that uh black's
pawn chain here will just stay intact
forever
and i'm not really sure how else you
kind of create any active play right now
so i'm expecting duda to capture on
passant and
when black recaptures maybe with the
queen
and then we start trying to round up
this
loose pawn in white's half why was the
queen and not with uh the pawn or or
even the knight unfortunately if you
take with the pawn um here the rook
would fall off in the corner so white
would win a piece
if you take with the knight which he
didn't go for in the end then white's
knight does get a nice square in the
center attacking this pawn one once and
twice he took with the queen instead
meaning that if white's knight jumps in
now then it can just be captured it can
just be uh traded off very safely
all right yeah it looks like white's
better but still upon down temporarily
for duda they played quite quickly so uh
for in this game one duda and carlson
now young christophe duda in a little
bit of a thing so we're gonna go to
miami and uh i think you're standing
with tour director anora we saw a very
cool selfie by you guys a couple of days
ago and i want to remind you guys we
have a selfie competition today as well
a selfie to impress
simon williams
[Laughter]
uh
what do you think arnold what about tour
director do you think he could make a
selfie
as a hippopotamus and make it seem
credible
of course whatever you ask for me father
i'm more actually curious now about the
tour as a whole though because it is it
is
going extremely well so far i mean not
only the venue here at eden rock in
miami but it's also the players are
seeming to be happy and everything is
going as planned is this correct
uh more or less as planned of course
there's always funny elements when you
take full productions from one continent
to another but in the
great picture of things things are going
very very well my impression though
talking to the players quite a bit is
that they are complaining a whole lot
less than what i'm used to
good and that's also the impression that
i have that uh the setup we have here
and the balance between play and leisure
and being able to
rest between the rounds as well works
very well for the players so that's
that's something we're really happy with
i want to ask you about tomorrow because
there is a bit of a twist tomorrow it's
going to be opened up for audience to
come and watch there's been been chess
fans who's been able to buy tickets to
actually come and watch this live
how how is this going to happen
well we will open up the venue
so that we will rearrange the venue
tonight and uh open up have seats inside
the playing venue so it's going to be in
that sense more a normal chess event
that you can actually watch so players
but here you watch the players playing
online chess and there's but in addition
to that there's going to be a lot of
side events so it's a kind of a chess
festival here which is on the beach
symbols we will have uh
speeches with famous chess people so uh
it's going to be a really cool two days
no no chanting
we are not putting up for that but uh
let's see how the audience behaves
i'm not sure if they're gonna behave
because the ones who've been watching
here kyle seems to be quite engaged and
quite excited about getting to watch
chess at miami beach we actually have a
suggestion from the studio we were
talking about it yesterday we want to
see those foam fingers for uh chess like
go magnus or go prague i don't know if
you guys have time to make that uh
before tomorrow though
foam fingers are not do you think that's
a good idea for the audience bring your
phone fingers
get it on
prague magnus do the foam fingers i'm
ready for him
love it love it it's going to be a great
two days for spectators in miami thank
you sweater and the
and of course the main attraction is to
watch the top players in action
today it's magnus carlsen against young
chris of duda we have a couple of moves
david we do have a couple of moves uh
white's knight parks itself on the edge
of the board and black bishop does the
same and i think we'll see a bunch of
exchanges right now we do see a set of
minor pieces leave the board there white
has temporarily won his pawn back but
i'm not so sure
things have changed maybe in magnus's
favor style-wise now he has won a pawn
again so black temporarily one pawn up
i'm not sure this will last too long
white's pawn structure is better than
the black pawn structure with those two
isolated pawns on the queen side on the
left flank of the board
but uh what do you guys think are we
just gonna see the vacuum cleaner come
out
head the game towards a draw the
computer still thinks white has some
advantage here
i i think so i mean
there aren't too many pieces on the
board and
i think
both sides are primed for making those
exchanges and when all those pawns get
eliminated on the left side then it'll
probably be just a draw like you've kind
of indicated
yeah so right now the black queen has
come down it's captured a porn i'm
guessing we'll see the queens disappear
i'm not sure whether you capture on
black's terms or whether you leave it
for a moment and this pawn is under
attack so i don't know whether we have a
timeout do we take a time out to just
push and say okay i'm going to win one
of these two guys next
i'm not sure whether this achieves too
much i guess in the current position the
alternative
for duda would be to get greedy and
capture this pawn but i'm slightly
reluctant first of all to allow any
checks on the back rank
i don't think there's any danger there
though uh maybe the one argument that
you could make for white for do
disposition is that uh in terms of pawn
structure this is still an isolated pawn
black's knights aren't too great right
now um he has captured the queens he
decided not to allow any risk so after a
queen trade we will see
perhaps due to do something about this
pawn in the middle either defend it or
push it up one square
yeah it does look very dry though and
it's a magnus type of position
totally um difficult to kind of suggest
something you know because both sides
have their
you know advantages and disadvantages i
thought that maybe he would retreat the
bishop just to kind of preserve the
integrity of his pawn structure and just
not allow any knight to spring forward
and cause some mischief
but um
here it's actually i mean what is the
situation if the worst comes the worst
and those two weak pawns fall off the
board i mean still is it going to be a
draw or is it kind of not so easy
yeah i'm not sure simon uh what you
think there i mean for example let's say
black just gives them away black just
gets active
um it's still unclear whether white's
five versus four advantage in terms of
pawns is uh sufficient here yeah
i think that's one case where the
bishop's not gonna be very great as well
i mean uh
we mentioned this yesterday when you've
got pawns all on one side of the board
the bishop's not gonna be a good piece
um obviously this would be ideal though
i mean this is the most that duda can
imagine and dream for is is to win both
of those pawns if he can win both those
pawns he will play on and on and on
because he's got an extra pawn
but i just don't think that's ever gonna
happen right i mean magnus is not gonna
drop that pawn and he's probably just
gonna exchange that pawn off for white
central pawn at some moment and as soon
as that exchange is made
they can pretty much shake hands
following the game yesterday really if
for those of you who are watching
yesterday the the liam liquon game
versus magnus it was very very similar
wasn't it everything all the pawns got
swapped off symmetrical structure and
they just agreed to draw
it looks it looks to me like it's
heading that way unless something
something happens i mean i still take
white here because black has a weakness
white doesn't so white is is still
better here um but it's it's where the
magnus can get rid of this one weakness
now yeah magnus uh looks very relaxed he
doesn't look too disturbed the valuation
bar up in white's favor i've got to say
i would love this position with white
but i would only love it if i can keep
these two pawns on the board
so big questions for duda how does he
prevent
that plan that simon has alluded to just
pushing this pawn at some point for
black and eventually trading off it
still takes a while because there is a
pin
along with c file but a clear plan for
magnus and it's unclear what duda does
in the meantime okay he retreats his
rook i guess this pawn push will just be
met by
white leaving it ignoring it keeping the
tension along this file so still some
work to do but yeah a draw is the most
likely result
all right well the bar is slightly over
to young christopher duda's side and
let's take a round
around the miami arena as always four
matches going on we'll start with hans
niemann he has lost all his matches so
far i heard some rumors about
a crazy hairdo today and i guess he's
always got a crazy hairdo
on sneamon yesterday
saying he just wanted to what what did
he say go into the ocean and never come
back he's been frustrating hansny
frustrated what do you expect from him
today simon well i'd love i i hope
someone could ask him what what what is
what room service he's buying right
because this is the question of the day
because in that same interview i think
he mentioned he's he spent something
like one thousand five hundred dollars
on room
as
services
i knew it was probably expensive for
miami but what's it gold-plated
gold-plated chips with uh i don't know
platinum burger that's got to be asked
what is he what is he buying for room
service i mean
caviar caviar smeared all over his bed i
don't know like what do you think i mean
it's like that is the question i'm
that's just going through my head at the
moment so what is he eating whatever
puts you in the mood to win on the
chessboard uh whatever he's been trying
hasn't really worked so far certainly
yeah but yeah it's in a tough match
today against ali reza faruja who's had
a great uh last few days and uh he wants
to win as much today and gain three
points he is fighting to catch up with
magnus and prague currently four points
behind them on the standings in the
tournament so far in game one the bar
all right maybe slightly over two
alireza russia's side
another game going on levon aronian
against anishigiri two players that know
each other very well levon saying before
today's round he thinks it's a little
cold in the in the arena so he's wearing
his jacket today and in game one here
against the anish who finally won a
match yesterday the bar actually did
slightly go up to levon's side we will
keep a close eye on this
and of course a very close eye on the
match between liam lea and pragnanda
prague on the same score as magnus
carlsen but the m he is a tough fight
and in game one the bar
so far roughly to the middle prize with
the black pieces in this game one
but we are following duda against
carlson you guys are saying it looks
like a jaw but why is the bar over to do
the side yeah i guess just for now at
least it's just the pawn structure white
has one porn island all of white's pawns
can connect if they need to if they want
to and black has that isolated
point pawn the isilani on c6 also
black's knights i just always feel super
uncomfortable when
we have these superfluous nights when
they protect each other but they're also
stuck on the squares because they're
kind of tied down uh they're on each
other's circuit especially what is
superfluous
superfluous is one one night is kind of
unnecessary it gets in the other night's
way um so
superfluous knights we would mean that
here black's knights they protect each
other which looks great but they are
just stuck fixed on their squares
and uh they're not very active i'm also
slightly worried about white's rook on
the seventh rank uh if i were magnus
the white rook on the seventh rank has
targets black's knight is maybe a target
in the center of the board black's pawns
on the seventh rank feel a bit
uncomfortable so all of these small
things stacked up probably add up to the
computer's evaluation of plus one uh
roughly one pawn advantage but
it is the type of advantage that could
just disappear in the space of one move
it could just fizzle away it's not
necessarily a long-term advantage right
now
and magnus is doing the right thing he's
spending around four minutes at this
point just trying to find a way to
relieve the pressure
and whilst magnus is thinking hard well
we do have a selfie competition and i
want to share with you a few selfies and
see whether they impress our gmg ginger
gm and uh siren plov guard says is
watching with a good book in his hands
from athens in denmark studying the
famous
hippo caracas
flattery will get you everywhere
i like your opening choice i like your
book and i'm sure simon does as well
and aaron hassan says gonna try and win
that hippo book and then he has a signed
board and i could see that once one of
the signatures was yasa sarawan but i
could not figure out who was the second
oh and
we see a porn move from magnus and
finally radio jagu says the hippo
speaks for itself and there she is with
her hippo what about this one simon i
like it you've got a bit of a hippo on
the screen there yeah i think that's a
step up i don't know in the background
but in her hand
i didn't i didn't say which one was the
hippo
there
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yeah well that that's good though there
is a hippo there so but i think we can
do better than this i'm sorry we can do
better i've seen no one in a river no
one acting like a hippo come on let's
let's up it please people let's bring
out our inner hippos you guys
well magnus he did move his uh simon
pawn harry yeah and this is a very kind
of magnus type of move just gaining
space it's never clear what this does um
in an end game i guess black's pawns
they connect they're they look very nice
and pretty over there but
uh magnus i think he's just passing the
move back to duda in the end magnus
after thinking for five minutes couldn't
really come up with a solution to
immediately kind of solve his problems
trade off pawns so he just said okay you
take the move i'm done thinking i'm not
necessarily working worsening my
position
and
the question the same question pretty
much lies on dude's shoulders now how
does he improve the position um it's
basically a standoff and neither side is
kind of 100 sure what to do i'm not sure
what either side should do either
what about you guys any possible plans
here for white to improve it looks like
white has maxed out the position of his
rook on the seventh rank his rook at the
bottom of the board looks great the
white bishop i guess needs to improve
the white knight maybe
name how do we do that maybe black was
worried about white pushing the g pawn
which is a rather strange idea but maybe
magnus felt he had to play this move um
to to stop white from
advancing possibly
we've seen that move maybe in from the
other side in some other games can be
very dangerous and because those nights
you've pointed out david which are kind
of gluing glued together um we're trying
to break defense of them in a bit of a
tactical way but the more more i'm
looking this the more i'm thinking like
you know i'm a bit biased because i know
magnus is with the black pieces if
magnus had the white pieces i'd be like
great chances to win i'd be like this is
a magnus position small advantage i
can't see actually how you're going to
swap off that weak pawn easily um i i'm
not sure what white's plan is i have to
say though as well but it still seems
like you know the more i look at this
more i think it's actually a little bit
tricky for black to to to uh get get
that move in and get that exchange this
is the big question
i'm just thinking inspired by idea you
mentioned that
white wants to be pushing the g pawn
forward just to destabilize those
knights i mean white can still threaten
to do that right by
first of all making a tiny little pawn
move
and
i mean magnus's last move also conceded
some squares for the knight
so if a pawn is not going to be arriving
at g5 maybe a knight can arrive there
too
and
still there are our ideas of
destabilizing the knight by
pushing the e pawn forward as well
yeah so
i i you inspired me simon before that i
was
stuck for a plan
wow wow
hey well i hate the nail on the head
there very good yeah and one thing i
will say about duda he's not patient
we've learned that uh in many of his
games so far on the tour that's a good
and a bad thing it means he seizes the
moment he goes for the he has this
killer instinct he tries to go for it
when he can but sometimes he does
kind of just rush a little bit here it's
unclear whether this is good or bad
in the previous position just to show
what happened white did push the pawn
two squares forward this pawn is
poisoned it cannot be captured by the
black knight because the black knight
would lose control over its buddy over
here and the other knight would drop the
knights need to stay in touch with each
other and that's why magnus after this
pawn push decided to defend one of his
knights so now there is a threat of
knight takes pawn
and dude has to back up his last move
the energetic pawn push
uh
with equally energetic uh follow-ups i'm
not sure what he wants to do here does
he want to keep pushing the pawn maybe
does he want the ivanka's move
potentially jumping in with the white
knight i don't think you should
necessarily get tempted and take this
pawn
there is something to say for this but
uh if your central pawn drops with white
now suddenly black is counter-attacking
against this pawn
it's getting very sharp actually white
can establish rooks on the seventh rank
and uh doubled rooks on the seventh
ranked seventh heaven this is very scary
for black
oh suddenly i'm not sure duder has uh a
variety oh he's gone for that yeah i
wasn't sure at first but i was kind of
talking myself into this move and maybe
uh it makes a lot of sense
uh this has happened knight takes pawn
and now duda does actually get his rooks
onto this dream
seventh rank is it is there a way
is there a way for black to bail out or
rook takes f2
knight g5 and then taking on f1 or
something like this is that or am i yeah
you might be right just just to go for
an ending which i feel should be
holdable for black yes so the idea is
that the black knight now is overworked
it needs to defend its rook but so if
you take the white knight then the rook
drops off and still problems on this
line
so simon you just want to get rid of as
many pieces as possible the rook is
dropping anyway you might as well get a
bishop in return
now you take the knight and at the very
end white actually wins uh the black
knight but after a bunch of trades as
you say you've kind of solved most of
your problems and uh here because you
have four connected pawns against
white's three despite the fact it's a
rook for night down i think black should
hold this one you're right just put your
knight in the middle of the board try to
locate it relocate it into the center
and
this one should be a straightforward
draw
yeah maybe dude i had something better
i'm surprised he played this last move
so quickly so i actually mentioned david
i mean
duder's strength and weakness is his
his urgency sometimes okay magnus is
keeping more peace on the board here but
it's it's his um
urgency to to do something right he
really feels like he you know he he
pushes very quickly and uh you know i i
i'm a bit surprised magnus went for this
line because uh just instinctively
keeping pieces on the board when you're
defending
can be dangerous in some scenarios um
is this a wise choice to keep because
the difference between this line and the
one that david pointed out is we have an
extra bishop for white on the board and
an extra knight for black on the board
so um and a set of rooks extra and a set
of rooks and those white rooks on the on
that line where we can see them
they say two rooks on the seventh are
very dangerous you can see those rooks
if you count up from the bottom that is
rank seven seventh heaven is the phrase
and they can be very very strong
coordinating like that so
it it seems this is a little bit
dangerous to play like that's very risky
yeah i think this is magnus playing for
a win because he will for sure have
assessed the line that you mentioned
there simon um the other variation and
he would have seen okay
black has some defending to do but it's
kind of 90 gonna be a draw and uh
instead choosing this one i'm just again
surprised by the speed i would have been
sitting there myself being like okay
this is one option this is another
option let's compare and contrast them
uh weigh them up evaluate all that stuff
magnus is like no i want to play for a
win keep an extra set of rooks on keep
an extra set of minor pieces and
worst comes the worst i'll still defend
anyway um
you're right i don't like it i guess
right now black's knights are very
active they're some night jumps that
dude has to think about maybe magnus had
one eye on the clock he was thinking
okay i'll put some pressure now it's
very hard to play with three minutes uh
when two knights are jumping around
also white's pawn in the center of the
board is a target for black's rook
now he was looking to the side though
yeah
not at the computer at all is that a
sign of calculating or
normally when you're not looking at the
computer you're either calculating or
you're trying to remember something or
you're just looking away and disgusting
so it's one of those three i don't think
magnus is necessarily looking away in
disgust but this last move is very
clever from duda he's got his king out
of the way it looks like he's blocking
his own bishop but his whole idea is
that he wants to push the white h pawn
forward two squares harry the age pawn
kick away one of black's knights maybe
we can show this because it's actually a
big threat right now um now for example
if black gets greedy takes this pawn for
a natural move
the knight gets kicked away and wherever
the knight moves when it moves i guess
it has to then rook takes pawn and
suddenly the white rooks have broken
through on the seventh rank
and there are going to be all sorts of
checkmating ideas for example um
this type of thing white maybe has
better but
one of these rooks going to the top of
the board might well
spell disaster for the black king this
one's still super complicated but
it looks
like white is the one with the tricks
black is the one suffering
yeah so how does magnus stop this idea
if we go back here this is clearly the
plan kicking away the knight and then
winning the pawn
once the knight loses defense of it
the knights is quite awkwardly placed on
g5 in general actually because yes you
know it's doing a fine job defending the
porn but that's all it's doing
so uh maybe it's time to kind of just
start attacking the white knight for
starters some white and white rook is
what i wanted to say so the most natural
square i guess would be this one yeah
but i was thinking of
going backwards yeah hit the rook and
then for example if the rook moves maybe
you go to this square so again you want
to defend this pawn if this pawn falls
the base of black's pawn chain then it's
disaster so you just defend this guy and
uh for example now if your other knight
gets kicked away as you say ivanka and
now you can move it to a less awkward
square actually now you're attacking
white's pawns and uh the key thing is
this knight does the defensive job and
this knight gap can't get kicked away
but magnus he decides uh not to go with
our judgment there our
suggestion he puts his knight in the
middle of the board instead and okay a
rook trade
can he get his rook in though david
because i mean there's two ways you can
play this as black right you can go you
can go sort of passive here you can
trade brooks
and try to hold i expect or if you're
really going for an adventurous idea
can you try to get your rook to check
the white king
and the idea of something like this
would be i'm trying to then coordinate
three pieces so the two knights are kind
of ready to jump forwards so they might
have the opportunity but combined with
the rook black will have three pieces
attacking but this is incredibly risky
yeah i mean the reason i say it's risky
because you're leaving white's brooks on
the seventh rank right
so you have to you know those rooks
we've we've noted how dangerous they are
so you're you're not doing anything to
stop them you're going on the counter
attack
but you know it could even end up with
some perpetual actually and what i mean
by that is the blackrook keep comes in
keeps checking the white king
and there's no escape ends in a draw
because there's no checkmate either yeah
this example the position could repeat
itself yeah
and i think white is forced to repeat
because if the king steps on the wrong
squares oh
there comes a third attacker three
attackers now uh pointing towards the
white king yeah i mean magnus he's so
brave i would be
terrified i think i wouldn't even even
have considered this option i would just
trade it off the rooks and try to curl
up into a ball and beg for the draw but
magnus is a far more aggressive
courageous player than most and he
brings his rook down you're right simon
this is the active way of defending and
active is always better than passive if
you have an option if you have a choice
so
um
yeah can do the run away from this check
it's not easy white's king is kind of
defending itself the white bishop is
just the worst piece on the board by a
mile
so i guess duda could force a draw as
you said maybe by pushing the h pawn and
this is probably the move which is going
to lead us now into that variation you
just demonstrated david oh man oh wow
he's playing for the win
wow there's a bunch of pre-moves there
look his face look at his face i think
he might have just has he blunted i
think he wanted to go back with his
knight and force the draw in the center
of the board but
that doesn't work
magnus he's reacted i think he has
blunted he's just
he rushed it he maybe hallucinated just
forgot about a simple trick
is he shaking his head slightly there
wow that wasn't a normal look was it i
mean
what's what's the problem david if the
knight goes back into the middle wow
look at it
yeah um so magnus i think uh let's keep
an eye on him but uh i think he just
missed that in the current position uh
this he wanted okay let's backtrack one
move he wanted to make a draw here
magnus he could have done that by kind
of
using the rook as we showed but instead
he moved his knight forward he thought
that he could bring the knight back with
the check and the position repeats
itself but maybe he just forgot that
white can remove this knight from the
board with a rook and at the end his
other knight is dropping and white
emerges with an extra bishop
and uh instead now in the current
position he did give a check with his
rook and the white king is moving
forward and look at this this black
knight it's incredible it's pretty much
trapped i mean it has a square or two to
go to but wherever you go david the well
i mean your anchor the world champion
has just blundered for the first time
this is just an outright blunder
i mean he had a draw a fourth draw by
just simply checking the king and he's
blundered and look at look at the bar
you know i'm getting used to saying that
now yeah oh look at the bar
it is i mean
you don't often see this i think i think
it's simply a blunder yeah and white's
king is actually super safe maybe as
well he just forgot the white king could
step forward the white king can go on an
adventure maybe this was the blunder
rather than the other line that i showed
maybe he just forgot that on the last
move the king doesn't have to retreat
doesn't have to go back you can step
forward
and suddenly where's this knight going
you only have two safe squares this one
or this one and either way no matter
where you go this pawn drops and as we
said the black king now is in massive
trouble the white rooks are doing a
great job of attacking
and what is magnus carlsen thinking
about now is he thinking about
how on earth will i save this game or is
he just realizing it's going to be a
loss
a bit of both uh first okay he gives a
check the white king now can capture the
black knight and magnus is threatening
checkmate so it looks like he was
disgusted for him uh with himself for
just 10 20 seconds there magnus but he's
recovered and this is what all the best
players do they just look for tricks
they look for ways to continue the game
and uh okay this is very sneaky there
was a massive threat of checkmate
black's rook was threatening to step
back two squares next to the white king
and trap it
magnus there he made a move without
using his hands he was just used
a bottle of water what did you call it
the magic wand the magic wand magnus's
magic wand
waving his magic wand around and he's
gonna have to use it really well and
this game is magic wanted to recover
isn't he
um although there's still some tricks
in the position white king is actually
caught in a mating net he needs to get
it out
how does black try and trap this white
king
i was i'd be very scared if i was white
here as well i'll be honest
i mean it's probably
probably winning and i am looking at the
bar when i say that but i'd still be
like hang on a minute my king if black
can check the king in any way it's
checkmate and you've got a poor knight
and rook which can potentially check the
king not really the pawn uh but it just
feels quite scary so you have to have a
lot of confidence play this and here
comes the knight so magnus is
threatening
two types of checkmate here if that
knight can just check the king
but david would you like yeah yeah
you're right if
white didn't move there if the black
knight had captured the white bishop or
if the black knight had gone back to the
center white's king was trapped
checkmated but look at this because
white's pawn jumped out the way the
white king has an escape route and the
white king retreats but the black knight
now we say nice to the rim of dim that
applies not just to the sides of the
board but also to the first rank and the
eighth rank and that black knight is
is it just gonna fall off is it just
gonna get trapped uh because the black
knight was forced to this square to
defend its rook
would it be a good idea for whites you
know because time is ticking down
and the position is still a tiny bit
complicated to maybe try to swap off
rooks by pushing the age board
yeah pushing the white h pawn forward
give a check yeah i mean the first move
that comes to my mind is be greedy just
go for this black knight i'm trying to
work out okay he captures a porn white's
rook could have also come down to the
first rank and attacked that black
knight um yeah maybe that wasn't working
instead
okay he's gonna go for it now so first
he kicks back the black king and now he
goes for this black knight and magnus
resigns about to lose another piece and
what a turnaround one blunder and deuter
took advantage wow dramatic start to the
day four magnus crawls and losing game
one to young christoph duda